How many jobs have you had?
How many do you expect to have
over the course of your career?
Well, the scary thing is that number
has historically been around 12.
But in the future,
I predict it'll be closer
to 20 or 30 or more.
And a lot of those jobs
don't even exist yet.
This future of work sounds overwhelming,
especially when you take into account
our old-fashioned system of resumes,
job postings and applicant
tracking systems.
It's hard enough to navigate
just a single career transition,
but you're far more
prepared than you think
to navigate your next job change
and all the ones that come after.
[The Way We Work]
I’m Dr. Michelle Weise,
and I advise companies
and educational institutions
on how to prepare workers
for successful and longer careers.
Right now, I want to talk about how you
can navigate that longer career,
starting with your next job change.
Number one, highlight your human skills.
When we talk about skills,
we tend to focus on hard skills
like coding, editing,
data visualization or budgeting.
But human skills need to share
the spotlight, too.
These are skills like adaptability,
collaboration, exercising judgment
or mediating tense situations.
They may not always show up
in obvious ways on your resume,
but they have enormous value.
To surface your human skills,
make a timeline of all
of your experiences,
both personal and professional.
Do you see patterns?
Have certain skills grown over time?
Maybe your stint as a barista
made you a great team player
or good at communicating in chaos.
Or maybe your experience
as a caregiver for a child
or someone with special needs
gave you strengths
like patience or empathy,
which informs how you design
human-centered digital products
or guide teams through a reorganization.
Human skills are deeply transferable.
You might surprise yourself
by how prepared you already are
for your next role.
Second, become a skills translator.
You need to translate your skills
into the language
of your prospective employer.
Research the industry
you want to move into
because the same skill
can have vastly different meanings
depending on the context.
For instance,
when a marketing position
is asking for a candidate
who's strong in communication,
they're usually looking for you to display
storytelling or branding skills.
But when a behavioral health position
mentions communication,
it's likely the employer is looking
for your experience with counseling
or crisis management.
Become their translator.
Third, find data in discomfort.
At work, when do you feel uncomfortable?
Maybe you feel out of depth
when people bring up a new technology
or a platform,
or maybe someone
at your current organization
got the raise or promotion
that you wanted?
Pay attention to those signals.
That kind of discomfort is good.
It's data telling you
where you need to level up.
Sign up for a course to get up to speed
on that new platform or application.
Transform that discomfort
around your skills gaps into action.
Finally, get picky.
You shouldn't be the only one
committed to your skill development.
Your employer should be too.
The next time you change jobs,
try to choose a company or organization
that is building talent from within.
Look at LinkedIn and see if people
have risen within the company.
Ask during the interview
whether there are clear road maps
for internal advancement.
The reality is, most companies
have so much work to do
when it comes to recognizing human skills,
spotting talent in unexpected places
and cultivating the careers
of their own employees.
You want an employer that takes
the long view on your career
and can help you fill
your skills gaps on the job.
Even if the job market
can feel broken at times,
remember, you can take control,
you can steer the process,
you can surface your hidden skills,
translate your strengths
and level up your gaps.
You can show employers new ways to think
about why they should hire you.
And when you do,
all of those lane changes ahead
will feel a whole lot less intimidating
and maybe even a little exciting.